then he went Donald Trump killed Donald
Trump I love Donald Trump but no more
dropped by the drop boxes are just so
bad no more drop boxes Dickinson hologic
and Stephanie cephahide
that was about a guy named a rhino named
Mitt Romney Mitt Romney real Beauty had
to give the American people their voice
back by building something called truth
truth Central he voted against Kate's
law and he voted for Obama
amnesty you know we've endorsed Dr Oz
we've endorsed
JP right JD Mandel and he's doing great
I've had more investigations than Jesse
ladies and gentlemen we don't even have
time for the songs because failed former
president Donald Trump twice indicted
twice impeached is now arriving at the
Miami Florida courthouse where he will
be arraigned on 37 counts 37 counts it
is completely out of control we have
video here from now this as you can see
the motorcade is there people are
pointing people are screaming there are
concerns of All Sorts about safety we
are witnessing history with tears in our
eyes and it is going to be an incredible
afternoon and subsequently evening
Republicans are starting to turn on
prompt we will have full coverage of
that maybe the get out of jail free card
that so many Republicans have been
waiting for we just don't know uh folks
welcome welcome come on in this is going
to be an incredible event we are on the
Ground Luke Beasley Luke the bee's knees
Beasley is uh going to be joining us
momentarily I actually have to figure
out the right way to let me see here I
want to make sure that we have
everything ready to go for when Luke is
ready because this is going to be truly
an historic thing he is interviewing
people and we're going to be talking to
people it's going to be crazy uh and
then we will see what happens with Trump
he will reportedly be mugshotted
although that may not be released
although maybe it'll leak I don't know
uh de sanctimonious
um and then he will not be handcuffed he
will not be handcuffed is the reporting
that we have so far
um let's see here I'll tell Luke great
uh we are standing by and Live join when
you are ready we are going to be live
folks from the scene of where all of
this is happening and it is indeed crazy
we're going to look at it all very very
soon the coupon code is indicted again
you all know why a self-explanatory
coupon code that I don't need to explain
here is another shot of what is going on
the failed former president twice
indicted twice impeached is in this
vehicle that you see here everything
must be just so for the safety of the
failed former president we don't know
whether
hold on what was that
oh let's see here
ah here we go
let's see what's going on here
we're linking up with Luke Beasley it's
all it's all happening
um
let's see here
there's multiple things going on here
it's actually pretty crazy
uh let's see oh okay we're on the ground
here
let me see the right way to do this let
me bring this in David hey uh Luke
you're on live folks we have Luke
Beasley on the ground in Miami Florida
Luke what's the scene down there
it is pretty wild I'm here with uh
what's your name Greg Donovan
California I wrote yesterday
awesome
and uh you want to describe the sights
and the sounds for the audience I've
never seen anything like this uh
supporters is as far as that I mean I
mean I'm into rallies I've seen but this
is unprecedented with the media here
it's uh
is bigger than I've been to the Super
Bowl the World Cup the Olympics and the
Oscars nothing ever like this
it's a sad day in American history I you
could compare it to the uh assassination
of Lincoln and Kennedy this is how bad
it is because he's gonna get my sentence
and if you realize it is a double
standard they're not in in indicting Joe
Biden when he was vice president he got
has the classified documents Luke can
you ask this gentleman what evidence
there is against Joe Biden so far
yeah what evidence against Joe Biden is
there so far well they have a lot of
documents I I don't know what documents
they have they do say that Trump has
some documents that are not considered
uh their top secret but I know he's
allowed to classify he did say he I mean
to declassify Luke can you ask this
gentleman when he says they have some
documents of Biden what documents does
who have and what evidence of
criminality is that what documents does
who have and what evidence do you have
to that they won't say anything that
what Biden has I haven't heard anything
but I've heard there's something about
something about invading Iran so how
does he know there's evidence of
criminality if he has no idea what he
has but if
if you're not even sure what he might
have exactly I don't know I I know so
then why does he want Biden indicted
it's a double standard that's what I'm
thinking I'm just
I'm saying if you don't know exactly
what Biden would have done wrong then
how do you know he should also be
indicted like Trump what why don't they
are why why doesn't the Department of
Justice go after him like they did Trump
and invade his home game set match okay
I think we got it yeah
Jesus all right thank you sir have a
good day incredibly powerful stuff as
you can see Luke the logic crumbling
under the simplest simplest questions
it's incredible is it all like this down
there
it's all like that and we have some wild
stuff that definitely will be able to
show on later shows that is pretty
stunning David has there been any
violence so far I hope the answer is no
no violence but already some pretty
unhappy people with me here are there
individuals who have threatened you
I wouldn't say threaten now okay all
right good and then as you know in
general what are the people they're
hoping to achieve do you know
showing their support for Trump
I'm glad it's nothing more than that at
this point uh-huh and do they do you
know how long they plan to stay or what
the end game is
I guess seeing Trump off
um seeing him what does that mean
as she comes in and out they have to
show their support you know oh I struck
with the big Trump Flags
uh lots of trump merch just showing off
do you get the sense that these are all
True Believers or are there people
grifting as well
the merch stands I would say are
probably more grifty but the supporters
are definitely fully bought in you know
I heard just recently during an
interview someone say you know who's
controlling all this right well one
person said the Jews of course
um and another person said Obama
was anybody able to tell you which Jews
are controlling it
oh no oh you know what I did oh that's a
problem I just messed something up I
didn't really look I I didn't I didn't
realize Luke that you were that you were
receiving audio through the other feed
so I closed it out now I understand yeah
can you hear me now
yeah the second person on the call is so
that I can hear you I gotcha did anybody
say which Jews are controlling
everything
oh gosh uh
specifically that word they just said
and I didn't really want to dive any
deeper but we also heard the normal
World economic Forum yep
um Schwab that type of stuff George
Soros of course if it comes up again I
would ask it would be an interesting
thing to say which Jews are controlling
it just as an interesting curiosity
I put a lot of money on Soros Dave okay
that's fair so listen Luke let's do this
because you've got a lot going on we'll
let you get back to getting the content
we'll get to the arraignment and then if
you're still going we'll reconnect with
you after if that makes sense
perfect let's do it all right let's do
it all right Luke Beasley wow uh Luke
Beasley is down there and it is crazy
what is going on we have to applaud what
is happening it is truly unbelievable
and what a job what a job Luke the bee's
knees Beasley is doing there
um welcome everybody if you're just
joining us it is an incredible day it is
an historic day the former president is
being again indicted and arraigned
37 counts potentially facing 536 years
in prison more likely I'm told is 20 to
100 years in prison now you may all be
wondering David when will you demand
prison time for Trump and the answer is
when he's convicted or if he cops a plea
I will demand that he be sentenced in
accordance with sentencing guidelines
that's called Law and Order folks
whatever you think the right is talking
about when they say Law and Order Law
and Order means we don't demand
imprisonment until someone's been
convicted if you care about Law and
Order well I do I do ladies and
gentlemen welcome welcome welcome I see
people still wondering what's Happening
Here everybody is welcome come on in
chakasecki says via Super Chat David get
an umbrella ready for magedonian Tears
today
also would you have Dr Ruth Ben geot
back on your show to discuss
authoritarianism
absolutely absolutely super chats coming
in feel free to keep them coming I can't
even keep up with everybody who is
dumping in twitch subscriptions hippie
chick and do you grock montelios and uh
Alice all of these great people I do
want to remind you this may only be the
first of two streams today because later
today Trump will be speaking from
Bedminster Bedminster if we get to 250
subscribers today I will then stream
tonight and the coupon code that you can
use at joinpakman.com is indicted again
you can do monthly or yearly folks this
is how we support Independent Media this
is how we support all the things that
we're doing you type in the code
indicted again Bing Bang Boom and
incredible things start to happen Okay
that's joinpakman.com I will thank every
one of you and we will pretend actually
have a second stream tonight depending
on how all of that goes also welcome to
subscribe via twitch or via any other
means that are available to you let's
take a look at some of the sights and
sounds on the ground here is live uh
live now from Fox let's listen I use
this thing called math
and so I'm looking at a lot of the
images that we've been showing you here
on live now and we showed you a bit more
of the crowd I want to actually switch
up one that we have right here so Andrew
you can actually get a view of it it
looks like it actually just changed for
some reason over to the White House
Press briefing but take a look at this
you've seen kind of the crowds like this
one that have been appearing there
outside the courthouse over the last
several hours is that what you'd expect
to see in a case like this
I wish I knew what to expect in the
indictment of a former president on
federal charges but all right so that
nobody knows what to expect I think is
the point Adam Johnson says via Super
Chat do they call it the wheels of
Justice because it's law and auto very
much well said I think that that is
absolutely the case welcome to Tool moo
our latest twitch Prime subscriber thank
you very much I appreciate that we have
a number of different uh cameras and
shots down at the courthouse we also
have Luke Beasley down there he already
interviewed one person for us he has
recordings interviewing interviews with
other people which he is going to send
us thanks to Desiree Delong and Angelica
Pilger for signing up on my website with
the coupon code indicted again let's
continue seeing what is happening down
at the courthouse by all reports Trump
has indeed arrived and the crowd is
getting agitated it is extremely hot and
humid in Miami Florida today we don't
know if everybody is wearing sunscreen
or is taking appropriate precautions
from the standpoint of heat stroke we
don't want what happened to producer Pat
at the finish line of a half marathon
last weekend to happen to any of these
magadonians down here let's listen to
the Newsmax coverage
well first of all I'll tell you what
what defense lawyers think generally
um you only want a speech well if your
client is locked up because you know you
want to get your client out of it as
fast as possible that would be probably
the only time otherwise look let me be
honest with you is that there's the
prosecution wants to go to trial always
faster than the defensive prosecution's
been working on this case forever
they're ready to go the defense is
essentially just getting the formal
charges now plus and this is true is
that over time prosecutors cases can
fall apart I mean I've seen trials that
don't go to trial you know for a year or
so in the meantime maybe a key yeah so
this is the standard legal analysis
where as a defense attorney you almost
always just want to delay as much as you
can Witnesses forget Witnesses die
evidence is misplaced prosecutorial
priorities change as a general principle
if you can as a defense attorney you
delay as much as you can barring some
particular circumstances super chats
continue to come in we all received an
early Trump birthday present by having
him in indicated yet again absolutely
thanks Ann for the 20 Super Chat
craving beer says I'm getting my popcorn
ready and by popcorn I mean whiskey
Adam says keep spreading the good word
David thank you well thank you sir and
also thank you to Amanda colon
Dennis McKenzie and Don Taylor for
signing up on my website with the coupon
code indicted again indicted again is
the coupon code let's look at a couple
of other things that are happening on
the ground there we have so much video
that is incredible and we will of course
of course get back to Luke Beasley who
is on the ground down there
um let's see what we have
Marco Rubio is on Fox we don't Rubio is
a true loser okay here's Trump arriving
[Applause]
[Music]
incredible
[Applause]
it's quite a country we have here that
is for damn sure that is for damn sure
um let's see what else I I just really
don't care what Rubio thinks you know
it's like I acutely do not care what he
thinks
um a lot of video of trump on his way to
the courthouse
this guy isn't this guy uh yeah
for Giada blow
Forgiato blow
yeah very good Trump posting to Troth
one of the saddest days in the history
of our country we are a nation in
Decline I want to remind everybody
it is a good thing it is a good thing if
everyone
who appears to have broken the law is
held accountable there should be no one
above the law
um I want to thank the following folks
for signing up on my website Donald J
Trump Sergey griu
Ryan wallstrom Sal Otero
uh Andrew weissert and David Smith folks
using the coupon code indicted again
Miami Police is huddling about the plan
going forward a lot of action As Trump
has been inside the courthouse now for
about five or ten minutes it is believed
that he will be mugshotted fingerprinted
not handcuffed and in 54 minutes we'll
face a judge and they will establish
next steps in this federal case super
chats are coming in almost faster than
we can handle them let's see what is
being said will Walt be released on his
own recognizance without a bond As Trump
will be Walt is Trump's body man who has
also been charged let's see what I don't
even know what we're looking at here
uh it looks like camera people going in
very interesting stuff we don't know the
answer to that Jack from Canada this is
a fairly small crowd I hope they haven't
brought guns and don't end up doing
something stupid but I agree with that
100 percent
um does Trump know he looks like a clown
no
he doesn't
good thing Donald J Trump beefed up
those classified document laws yes
do you think the recently leaked
transcript will be entered into evidence
I I do not know these are the sorts of
questions we have to we have to wait on
thank you to Sal atero as well as Jody
bundrick for signing up at my website
folks this may be a very long day of
streaming we have this event right now
later today we have Trump speaking at
Bedminster in New Jersey and we are
likely going to be covering that if we
fill this bar to 250 I can't thank
enough all of the folks that are signing
up via twitch it looks like uh five
six seven more I'm trying to keep up
let's continue actually let's listen to
what Newsmax is saying you mentioned
before the midterm elections he didn't
tell everybody the day or two before
midterm elections that he had those he
waited until January January 10th to
talk about those doctors not as loud and
obnoxious as president Trump but
certainly it doesn't seem like he was
quick to tell the American people it's
another form of obnoxious behavior so
all these four people I don't think one
of them were Pence Biden Hillary Clinton
or five Bill Clinton or Trump had would
ever betray the betray the country I
don't think so but they're all very
sloppy hoarders and there's a legitimate
question whether to be treated similarly
or fairly and I think one of the
problems with President Donald Trump is
is that he thumbs his nose at the system
yeah well so she she see that is the
that's the heart of the dishonesty of
these right-wing narratives she says
well you know all of these people had
things related to classified documents
the only difference is Trump is thumbing
his nose at people
thumbing his nose in this case is
criminality thumbing his nose in this
case is obstruction of justice it's not
a minor thing where it's everybody kinda
did the same thing but Trump thumbs his
nose no
when it came to Hillary Clinton she
turned over 30 000 emails and cooperated
when it came to Joe Biden he
turned over documents that were
um uh in his possession immediately and
said investigate me go ahead I will
fully cooperate Trump had months during
which he didn't turn over documents
arguably acted to hide documents
instructed instructed lawyers to maybe
just lie and say we don't have any
documents a server room flooded
destroying surveillance evidence even
though they are denying that that was
deliberate okay we'll give him the
benefit of the doubt on that but is
still extraordinarily suspicious these
are crimes it's not a footnote
it's not a footnote that Trump thumbed
his nose you've got to be kidding me
a thank you to Jason sickmeyer Zach Arad
and Madison Hughes signing up on my
website with the coupon code indicted
again also big thank you to Tiga and
high shelf Comics store as well as
hamather
uh signing up via twitch I appreciate
that very much Donald Trump has
surrendered Donald Trump has surrendered
and is inside the courthouse NBC news
reporting that Trump will be arraigned
alongside his co-defendant Walt nauda 40
years old 40 years old that is Trump's
body man as they like to say 37 federal
felony counts Trump conceivably facing
536 years in prison although he would
almost certainly not face anywhere close
to that
but we will see let's not get ahead of
Justice let's not get ahead of Justice
out of curiosity what is on Fox News
they're in a commercial right now all
right we will get back to that I am
curious about that super chats keep
coming in Matt says appreciate you David
thank you Matt I appreciate you
coach John jacked verb when the wealthy
and Powerful get indicted
David thumbing your nose at legal orders
from a judge's Free Speech exactly this
is all just about taking away Trump's
speech
bit Greece asks if I read the book The
psychopath whisper by Kent Keel I have
not sounds interesting though
tomorrow will come sending General
support I really appreciate that what
you do in the rest of progressive media
space do is so important I appreciate
that very much thank you
a great day to all not under Federal
indictment for Espionage well said
literally all conservative news coverage
buttery males buttery males I know
hit that like people yep folks why
haven't people like this stream please
anti-fascist pro-democracy dumping in a
50 Super Chat saying I feel so disgusted
by the amount of Latinos protesting in
favor of trump the Associated Press
stream recorded a lot of them they just
screamed communism speaking of which
Associated Press YouTube stream I wanted
to have that stream up let me see if I
can find it
Associated Press
because that is a that is a heavy stream
yeah here we go
[Music]
that is the wrong one
there it is okay actually this seems
like the same no similar streams oh it
is getting hot folks let's see what's
going on
all right someone's holding a guitar in
the air and it's all pretty uh pretty
remarkable stuff Gary asks is it
possible the doj will push for a ban of
holding federal office along with
potential prison time it may be
something that's negotiated
um if Trump isn't above the law he
should be handcuffed finally the day has
come thank you for your hard work and
prime example David love from Portugal
thank you
thank you Anne just now my son said
they'd reconsider my Boomer title
because I'm watching here instead of
Legacy Media that's Toady back yeah Tony
Beck's kids give Toady some credit
please what are the next steps regarding
the recusal of Judge Cannell Cannon
major conflict of interest I don't know
the next steps that's a question we're
watching very closely and I hope to have
more information about that tomorrow if
Trump is found guilty is there a legal
mechanism that prevents him from running
for office not as far as I understand it
did you see the clip of the maggot who
said Trump was being indoctrinated
instead of indicted yes we used that on
today's podcast so it's wild
according to the USA Today and the
independent Trump won't have a mug shot
that is what I read as well
on yesterday's show you misread War Dyer
it's French no I understand that in in
American jargon they just save War dire
I know that it's not the French
pronunciation
um but I do appreciate the uh
well-intentioned correction thank you to
Thomas Hitman and Andreas Romer for
signing up on my website ladies and
gentlemen if you are here for the first
time we are covering the Trump
indictment live live live live look at
this crowd outside the Miami Federal
Courthouse in which Trump currently
finds himself we don't know how long
these proceedings will take some believe
they will be relatively short once they
start at 3 P.M others say it could
extend more than 60 or 75 minutes as
they did when Trump was first arrested
in New York we will potentially have a
second live stream tonight where Trump
will be speaking from Bedminster New
Jersey I assume telling some of the same
corrosive lies that we have heard from
him for a very very very long time if
you are here for the first time I would
love it if particularly you're watching
on YouTube you would hit that subscribe
button it costs absolute lutely nothing
nothing and we are pushing towards 2
million subscribers which would be an
incredible Milestone to reach we are at
1.737332 million as of this point in
time you will also be notified about
future streams which is really the most
important thing you can imagine at this
point in time uh we have action let's
see what's going on I'm leaving right
now Jason Miller Jason Miller one of his
attorneys
right there I believe she will be Jason
Miller is not one of Trump's attorneys I
think she's meeting uh the Press uh I
believe John Huddy may be asking a
question right uh they're they're
setting this up I believe so the Press
can hear what a lady has to say all
right so it looks like we're going to
hear from one of Trump's lawyers very
very soon she is
um pounding her Fists in the air uh
pretending like any of this is even
remotely good for Trump it's obviously
not we'll see if we have any other shots
of this it looks like they are setting
up some some kind of press availability
here which we certainly want to hear and
see
um people Milling about and let's see
what is happening over on Fox News
hmm whatever reason it just seems like
Fox News is persistently in a commercial
I have like a mild curiosity as to what
they're talking about
but uh let's see if we can get this
video
extraordinarily glitchy stuff oh here we
go Senator to have a classified document
in his or her possession they're allowed
to look at them in a sensitive
compartmented information facility a
skiff all right so we are monitoring
this let's see if we can get a little
better quality here there we go that's
much better all right so it seems like
soon Trump's lawyers are going to speak
and that's going to be interesting
welcome to the duck of death Tina tiru
McKinley pyro Avalanche of spinach and
weather boxer via twitch I really do
appreciate that also big thank you to
Linda Bentley Tanya and Matthew Sullivan
for signing up on my website with the
coupon code indicted again the best way
to support our work is to sign up on my
website the second best way is with the
coupon code indicted again let's listen
representative Hillary Clinton critten
Joe Biden himself critton retained
possession of classified documents that
have not been prosecuted they committed
no crime and none of them came into
possession of those documents while they
were president
none of them were president
who as the head and sole member of the
executive branch
has the power to summarily declassify
documents
the decision to pursue charges against
President Trump while turning a blind
eye to others
is emblematic of the corruption that we
have here
[Music]
we are at a turning point in our
nation's history I'll say they're
targeting prosecution
of a leading political opponent
is the type of thing you see in
dictatorships like Cuba and Venezuela
I'll address this later it is
commonplace there for rival candidates
to be prosecuted
to jail what a loser what is being done
to the president Trump should terrify
all citizens of this country no these
are not no ideals that our democracy is
founded upon
this is not our America
thank you wow
right now now inside the courthouse has
he been arrested has he been
fingerprinted uh has a mug shot been
taken walk us through what's happening
here now president Trump is in a very
unique position where he doesn't need to
be given a mug shot obviously he's not a
Flight Risk he literally candidate of
the GOP at the moment literally has a
job he
keep a secret service and it will all be
handled seamlessly
guys
the attorneys what what is this thing
wow
all right I'll lead a hobby there a
spokesperson for president so this is
one of the most important
details of this entire thing
The Defenders the magats the magedonians
whatever you want to call them they want
you to believe that everyone is in
danger if they can quote do this to
Trump
but let's think about that we already
knew that we all are in danger in the
sense that if we do something that is
apparently Criminal
we are not going to have any easy path
out
we are going to have to go through a
process
that too often the wealthy and the elite
don't have to go to through we shouldn't
be afraid because Trump is getting
indicted we should be reassured because
Trump is getting indicted when there is
evidence of criminality you should
investigate when you believe a crime has
been committed you should present the
evidence to a grand jury if the grand
jury says yes then you should indict and
then you should have the opportunity to
prove your case and Trump should have
the opportunity to defend himself we
already know that that's the way it
works for everybody else there's no
looming Dark Cloud of if they can do
this to Trump they could do it to anyone
they already do it to anyone the
question was Will trump potentially be
held accountable now that all being said
I think it is reasonable
say even if this is the right thing
given the evidence and it is
there is a crossing of the Rubicon where
the United States has now become a
country where sometimes former
presidents must be prosecuted it is true
that that was not the case prior to
Trump and it now is the case but the
person or people or organizations to
blame for that are not partisan
Democrats or Joe Biden or whatever the
case may be as Republican Chris Christie
said last night
Trump is to blame for that it is Trump
who did things no other president has
done that led to this moment it is not
prosecutors who put the United States on
the list of countries that sometimes
prosecute former presidents it is
Trump's actions that put himself on the
that made the U.S enter the list of
countries that sometimes prosecute
former presidents do not allow them to
trick you
this is a reassuring
event
and look at these lunatics here
Luke Beasley is on the ground and we are
going to be hearing from him again later
uh let me see if I got any message from
him no not yet I I have to thank folks
people are about to crash my website are
signing up in droves I so appreciate
your support today on such a such an
important day Vil vatovara Nico hootenen
Thomas alacio Moon child straver Robert
old Droid and Richard Crocker all
signing up on my website I really
appreciate that the coupon code is oh
that's not where we are indicted again
if we get to 250 we will have a second
stream tonight from Trump's Bedminster
thanks also to Trill Phil signing up via
uh twitch if you're watching on on
Twitch welcome make sure you're
following we will have another uh we
will have another stream tonight let's
see what else is going on here let's
hear from a little bit of the Newsmax
interviews and president Trump needs all
of us to support him we the people need
to speak up and stand for what we
believe is right right what do you think
of the charges he's facing
I believe the charges are bogus right
and what I believe about the crowd and
all the people that came you know I
actually spoke to somebody earlier and I
came from California what do you think
about that I think it's wonderful that
we have people from across the country
supporting our president I believe that
this has been one of the more peaceful
protests or rallies I shouldn't say
protests that I've ever been to right
and uh things are going well today and
yes people I've met from various
different states about seven of them I
think it's wonderful amazing and why do
you support uh former president Donald
Trump
it's not even supporting president Trump
as much as it is supporting the system
and I believe supporting the system
would be hey we have evidence of
criminality let's allow due process to
run its course these people are truly
truly horrifying Todd says via Super
Chat loved when you started to refer to
Trump as failed former president maybe
time to change to Federal Criminal
defendant yeah it's twice arrested twice
impeached failed former president Donald
Trump that's really the name now
um maybe when Trump left office he
didn't say I will be back in some form
maybe Trump said I will be back with
some forms yes his indictment forms the
smocking gun says love the maggoteers I
need more salt for my steak
honest question if Trump did flee would
he still have Secret Service protection
I don't know the answer to that that's
an interesting question
this is why America is great everything
according to the law even for Trump
let's let's see it to its conclusion
let's see thanks to Shel Nye the Science
Guy and elevated disc golf for the
twitch Prime subscriptions also thanks
to Jay tandoway for gifting five of them
and people asking if the code indicated
still works guys listen the top coupon
code right now on the website is
indicted again you can use the coupon
code sad Trump you can use the coupon
code indicated you can use any of the
coupon codes you want it's really up to
you
um it is it we they're all welcome
Victoria Titus using the code wow 22
there you go pulling out an old coupon
code from last year that is totally fine
all right let's see where do we want to
go with this actually
trying to think let me check in with
Luke
uh and see if Luke
wants to reconnect with us because a lot
is going on
want to reconnect now what do you have
going on you know Luke Luke's got it
he's got his hands full down there and I
know that he is producing a lot of
content for us for tomorrow thanks to
Patrick baransky for signing up on the
website number 76 today this if you're
just joining us you haven't really
missed anything yet other than Trump
arrived and his propaganda lawyer said
that Trump is defiant that's where we
are right now Trump is inside being
booked the official arraignment is about
to start in about a half hour we're
covering all of it Trump then expected
to speak tonight from Bedminster which
we may also cover as well thanks to
Joshua John Stone welcome Joshua using
the coupon code indicted again and his
new member number 77 today let's uh go
over here and just see if we have any
other choice videos from down on the
ground this is what I like
um
Karine Jean-Pierre asked is Joe Biden in
any way involved in this you have been
clear that you don't want to politicize
the indictment but the president's
opponents have accused
accused doj so just to be clear can you
say categorically that President Biden
was not involved or influenced at all
any of the decisions into indict the
president not at all he was not involved
this is the president has been very very
clear the Department of Justice is
independent he wants to restore that
independence of of the Department of
Justice and that's what you've seen
that's absolutely correct and there are
people saying how dare Biden not comment
on this I don't need Biden to comment on
this I need Biden to be president I
don't care what Biden thinks I don't
need Biden's opinion he should have
nothing to do with the prosecution the
indicement the indictment just be
president that's it that's all I need
him to do CNN reporting an incredible
moment Donald Trump under arrest Collins
of Miami thanks so much let's go to the
other side of the courthouse where we
find Paula Reid who has the new
information Paula
that's right we were learning from
inside the court that the booking
process is now complete now that was
going to look more or less like it would
for any other defendant former president
his attorneys had some paperwork to fill
out is expected that he would be
fingerprinted but they weren't going to
do a mug shot or anything like that but
in a short time he will go before a
Magistrate Judge and they will read the
charges that have been filed against him
he's expected to plead not guilty and
that is defense table will be Todd
Blanche and Chris kais he's the former
Florida solicitor general remember as we
covered on today's show that Donald
Trump even hours ago was struggling to
find lawyers to represent him which is
an extraordinary extraordinary situation
uh let me see if we have anything else
here that I want to oh Mitch McConnell
asked about this given that the former
president is facing a Federal indictment
and these serious allegations could you
still support him if he becomes the
nominee even if he's convicted well look
the Republican
campaign for the nomination is already
been going on for six months
going to be going on for a year longer
and I'm just simply not going to comment
on the candidates we've got a bunch of
them all right so Mitch McConnell with a
cop-out Noah no big surprise
um
all right so that's what's uh that's
what's going on there let's uh dip in a
little bit to Fox news coverage see what
they're up to he's criminalized this
based on the National Security documents
uh the presidential records Act is
designed for presidents and there is a
real argument about
you know whether they can take the
documents where that line is uh Lyndon
Johnson took documents we met reference
Bill Clinton
um and and what ended up happening in
that Administration was Sandy Berger and
Sam Berger and the socks yeah he took
them out of the archives out of the
archives so there's a real
question about the criminalization of
this they they lay it out in the
documents as a national security issue
but there is some argument to be made
about about this and you've seen the
former president kind of touch on that a
little bit so you know you really only
need to go to William Barr a republican
who said the argument that these are
just matters of presidential records and
not criminal records is bogus and it
went out the window when Trump
obstructed and Trump lied and directed
lawyers to lie and then just hid the
documents for months he was given every
opportunity to keep this as an issue
just of records and it went out the
window because of what Trump did it's
that simple there is no it it and if you
talk to other serious attorneys they
will tell you the exact same thing let's
look at some other messages coming in
from people big thank you to Fred imandi
Robin Barnett and Eric forstrom signing
up on my website with the coupon code in
guided again super chats are flying in
Nick says do you think this helps
desantis's chances yeah I think anything
that makes Trump seem problematic as a
candidate
helps DeSantis except for the blowback
where maybe people get behind Trump
because they feel he's being railroaded
however I believe we are getting to the
upper limit of that ladder group I think
from here on out and in particular
because more and more Republicans are
increasingly turning on Trump I'll have
a report about that tomorrow I think
from here on out further indictments
hurt Trump and help DeSantis that's just
my opinion just my opinion every
Floridian should be furious that this
clown Entourage and use of the police
for this is costing them millions of tax
dollars
David sir do you think they're not doing
a mug shot because the cultists would
instantly be selling it on a t-shirt no
I don't think that's why
I don't think I don't think that's the
reason why
um
big thank you to Cindy woodfork
who just signed up on my website and his
new member number 83. uh just as a
reminder the actual arraignment is
scheduled for the top of the hour 29
minutes from now Trump is already here
he has reportedly already been booked
and he is now presumably in some kind of
holding room awaiting uh awaiting the
start of proceedings at 3 P.M let me
make a small adjustment to our shot here
there we go that's just a little I only
want the best for the audience if you
are just joining us this is a stream
where I will give my opinion I always
get when there are large news events
people who just stumble onto the channel
and then they're Furious that I'm not
just down here in the corner saying
absolutely nothing there are other
streams for that if that's what you want
this I'm David hi this is my channel uh
what I would love for you to do if you
are so kind is if you're watching on
YouTube just hit that subscribe button
costs nothing really helps us out if
you're watching on Twitch make sure to
hit follow if you're watching on
Facebook quite frankly I don't know what
there is for you to do it's very very
much unclear if usually what people do
on Facebook is send me anti-semitic
messages sadly sadly that's what a lot
of people watching on Facebook do but
we're still live on Facebook and we may
be live tonight with Trump's statement
from Bedminster these proceedings could
last anywhere from 15 to 20 minutes all
the way up
all the way up to about an hour 15.
welcome to uh deeper shades of house our
friend with 37 months subscribed on
Twitch I really appreciate that thanks
also to Derek kittner really appreciate
that we are on the ground in Miami with
Luke the bee's knees Beasley who will
also be doing a little fill-in work for
me next week as I will be at a wedding
very very strong wedding we'll reconnect
with him soon thanks to Katherine Jones
Natalie and Kyle consiglio and Susan
Whitaker all signing up on my website
with the coupon code indicted again
which is an incredible thing it really
is let's listen to just a couple of
voicemails that are coming in from
people uh about the proceedings that we
are looking at right now
I don't know if you caught Elena Hobbit
Trump's call girl uh just had a
she just had a a Podium speech and he
said when she said Hillary Clinton she
said Hillary Clinton yep Hillary Clinton
they just have a lot of trouble saying
any the names of any of the people that
they
that they consider to be their political
opponents which is a very interesting
thing for sure update on the um Spotify
album The Spotify album is going to be
released uh within a few weeks we are
putting the final touches on it which is
a great thing
Gadget asks via Super Chat how do we
know he won't be denied bail and miss
his Bedminster press conference
um I I would bet that that doesn't
happen by the way any current book
recommendations yeah I just read Waco by
Jeff Gwynn really good about uh David
koresh and the Branch Davidians
um
what else that's my my recent
non-fiction recommendation I guess
thanks to Dave Harrington for a very
powerful 50 Super Chat Sam says can you
chant lock them up no remember I'm for
Law and Order so I don't randomly demand
people uh people get locked up when they
haven't done anything wrong uh or I'm
sorry when they haven't been convicted I
think better said okay Luke Beasley's
about ready to join us just join the
Zoom
when you are ready
all right we're going to be hearing from
Luke Beasley down in Florida in a moment
thanks to Robert Parker for signing up
on my website with the coupon code
indicted again I am so flattered by
people supporting Independent Media it
is such an important thing and I really
can't thank you enough we are only at
the beginning of what is going to be an
extraordinarily long day
um let's just see if we can get Luke
here
uh he should be with us any moment
let's just make sure that he has the
right
link
oh wait it's not hold on a second says
that he is waiting
oh here we go
here we go here we go here we go
here we go
okay here we go all right we are back in
collect connected with Luke the bee's
knees Beasley down in Miami Florida
um oh wait we've got the wrong here we
go this is the one we want nope that's
not it here we go
let's unpin
and then here we go Luke are you with us
what is going on down there what are
people anticipating
I'm with you I don't think they're
anticipating uh very much just kind of
standing here like I said showing their
support and actually we just bumped into
nearly cherry lake and lots of people
were saying that she was going to be our
next vice president what do you think of
that David oh boy it is quite a scene
down there now Luke just so you know
your video is Frozen we have audio but
your video is completely Frozen like an
ice cube
um and so I don't know if we need to
restart that or whatever in case maybe I
know that there are technical problems
but uh there's Luke now it's live you're
a couple pixels wide but it is live yeah
yeah you're back
um do you so Trump is yeah
3pm does anybody there know how long the
proceedings are going to last
no one has any idea um I would
definitely not rely on the individuals
I've been speaking to for that
information either because I just talked
to someone who said actually under the
law Trump can't commit crimes so since
he's president he can't commit crimes I
said do you mean former president no no
still president can't commit crimes so
this is not exactly a group of people
you would go to for legal analysis it
sounds like you're saying
probably not and that's what's
interesting
recently on my
defense of this whole uh legal trouble
that Trump said it doesn't have anything
to do with disputing the facts most of
the people all the people I've talked to
so far haven't actually laid eyes on the
indictment itself or any reporting about
what the indictment is alleging it's
just no the law doesn't say what you say
that it does the presidential records
act means Trump can do whatever he wants
with whatever document that he wants and
uh also Hunter Biden's laptop yes so you
know there's this old illegal adage Luke
which I know you're familiar with if the
facts aren't on your side you argue
process and if the process isn't on your
side you argue facts but what is
happening with a lot of these folks seem
to be they don't know the facts and
don't understand the process so they
just argue conspiracy theories
that's exactly what it is and I'm
looking forward to your audience seeing
some of these interviews I just talked
to
an individual who believes Trump is
still in control of the military but
it's also being persecuted by the
federal government what's in control of
the federal government and uh Biden is
actually an actor who has the real Biden
died a long time ago so I don't know
interesting stuff to say the least would
you say what has I want to be sensitive
with this question because mental
illness is such a serious thing but
being down there
is what is the what is the prevalence of
mental illness among some of the people
that are there
and I we asked this with total total
empathy but do do you feel that there
are just people who are suffering there
and don't really know what's going on
as you said you're gonna try to be very
sensitive with my words I think
I'll
I'll proudly say I'm not properly
educated to do that analysis of the
psychological situation of a lot of
these individuals but definitely some
beliefs that are so far from anything
that I could possibly engage with that I
don't even try I just kind of let them
talk about what they believe and it's
too far from even a few miles away from
reason that there's no reason to
um to engage in those conversations
definitely I can't uh I can't feel
comfortable talking about their
psychological
state has there been you know the things
you mentioned so far Trump is really in
control of the military or Joe Biden
died and has been replaced by a body
double Etc most of that stuff we've
heard before at least anecdotally is
there any new conspiracy theory you
heard there
oh gosh no I don't think any new uh a
lot of broken record stuff but every
time it's still it still blows my mind
the only difference is that the
indictment is looped into the conspiracy
theories now
um like I mentioned previously most
people
all the people I've talked to so far
don't even believe there's a single
chance that any crime was committed and
one of the things I'm interested in is
if they believe that Biden did incorrect
things incorrect things with classified
documents
I never understand why that means that
Trump also shouldn't be held accountable
because they want Biden to be held
accountable but not Trump even though
obviously the facts of the case are far
far more
um severe yeah it would be interesting
on that to say to some of these folks
Hey listen you know I'm with you
everybody should be investigated they
figured out Trump committing some crime
so they've charged him why is that a
problem they're investigating Biden and
they'll charge him if he committed a
crime that it would be interesting to
posit it that way to some of these
people
definitely and as you've definitely
um observed in the past a lot of times
there's an answer for everything
uh not attached necessarily to any facts
or logic but it's never the bombshell
moment or the mic drop moment that you
wish you could have where you're like
wait don't we believe in Law and Order
don't we want people to be investigated
for crimes left right and center and
right here look they've uncovered
evidence of crime why not hold them
accountable just like if it were to be a
Democrat but they'll have some answer
is there any anti-trump uh presence
there or is it basically just pro-trump
I would say just
some anti-trump we just got uh involved
in a conversation between an individual
on the left and on
the right sorry lots going on
um and it was getting pretty heated or
some of kind of interface arguments but
so far the smaller population of
anti-trump people here aren't causing a
ruckus with the protron people that's
good and what is the screaming that's
going on in the background
it looks like a news reporter of some
kind recognized a friend of his now he's
interviewing him uh we can move back do
you want to hear from another supporter
oh sure sure
David yeah yeah we're glad to hear from
another supporter
all right give me one second wow Luke
really doing any of you all interested
in getting
God's work down there this is wild David
backman
just kind of hear why you're here what's
your what you're doing
um
[Music]
and do you think that Trump is uh still
the rightful president yes
yes and do you think that means he's
serving in office right now or he's just
he should be
he should be there's a corrupt evil
clown that's sitting at my White House
and that's Biden that is Biden
as corrupted evil family
and all the corrupt and evilness in
Congress
they all need to be gone
yeah
can you ask this individual what states
do they believe Trump won that Biden got
electoral votes from
what um what'd you say
gotcha in what states do you think that
Trump actually won the official
narrative is the Biden one
uh does this person thinking Trump
actually won California there's a lot
more red in California than people think
they do huh in the mainstream media
doesn't show it so yeah he won
California what about Connecticut all 50
states went for
Connecticut okay yeah
Kent Luke can you ask in Connecticut
where are all of the Republican voters
hiding
uh before do I read I I think maybe the
one that didn't go red would might be
New York but I think California went red
so if all of these states are actually
if all these
can I ask the question
if all these states are going
red or they're going blue but they
should be going red where all the
Republicans hiding
in their houses
they're afraid because of January 6th
but the election was before January I
was there on January 6th
and the FBI came and rated
and I'm sitting right here Luke I'm not
afraid and you ask them Luke Luke let me
know when you can hear me
yeah go for it David can you ask them if
the reason that the Republicans are
hiding in their houses is January 6th
the election was before January 6th so
why were they hiding
actually voted for Trump in 2020 but the
reason that the Republicans aren't
making themselves seen is because
they're hiding in their houses because
of January 6th but January 6 happened
after 2020. so before uh
after the 2020 election so if they were
scared of January 6 during the election
that happened before January 6th how
would that make sense
I'm saying that they're not out here now
because they don't want what happened to
to the people at January 6 to happen to
them
they're scared but actually they are
starting to see the light
and they are actually starting to come
out
I mean okay look at all of this I don't
think that before the election I don't
think that we would have had this I mean
I went to a lot of flag waves and stuff
there's a lot more diversity In This
Crowd
what kind of diversity
a lot of controversy
it's here I mean it doesn't matter what
color you are you are a red white and
blue that's where we that's what we are
right here we're red white and blue
we're not black white whatever Asian
whatever we're American Patriots that's
what we are and we're standing up
because we're tired of what's going on
in our country what is going on I'm a
veteran and I definitely challenge all
veterans and what would you say is going
on in our country
um tyranny
also uh open borders
um they're they're they're flying the
pride flag which according to according
to me the only rainbow comes with an arc
a dub and an olive brand so can we zero
in on the flag one how is the pride flag
Tierney
because they want everybody to
how to Pride for activity
to go head to head with each other I
don't care if you're gay whatever LGBT
ABC
care but don't bring it down my throat
let me pose this to you what if what if
people what if people believe that the
pride flag actually stands for what
you're talking about it doesn't matter
if you're straight okay anyone can be
who they would like to be right that
should be that is the red white and blue
hey Luke can you ask him or her if
there's any group right now that is
getting too much respect
the red white and blue
Oh Glory you could call it whatever you
want but that is what America has pride
in not the not the rainbow thing I
yeah I mean so David can you restate
your question is there any group right
now that is getting too much respect in
her mind
is there any group right now in America
that's getting too much respect
too much respect
I don't think any group is getting any
respect
from our federal government
all right
science phobic homophobic I'm not scared
of it
that's fine you do you I I but don't
push it down my throat so so
next month I'm gonna have it's gonna be
Patriot pride month and my and my flag
is gonna be my colors are gonna be red
white and blue so I posted that on a
Facebook post you know what they took it
down as being that that's that's not
nice I'm like
yes hate speech
I can't speak to that particular thing
but
um hey Luke real quick can you ask
whether The Thin Blue lines
are we having a whole month of Pride
well I can answer that you ask a
question can I answer it can I answer
the question really quickly yeah so uh
the answer that people would pose to
what you just said is the reason why
there's a need for celebration about
being lgbtq is because of how long and I
think you would agree to this
historically people were demonized
assaulted killed for being those I
didn't and so sometimes but it's not
just about you right it's about other
people
yeah how come they don't fly that flag
at the car hey Luke you're totally
frozen and it's even affecting the audio
now
oh dear God now there's a truck
all right Luke hi David
Luke there's a lot going on down there
um we're gonna let you get back to it
and we're gonna keep an eye on
everything but wow what it what a job is
antifa running audio for you
I I gotta say my camera operator is is
completely bought off by antifa okay
listen we're gonna let you we're gonna
let you get to it keep in touch we'll
see if we can get a better signal later
and either way we'll have Luke's
interviews in high quality on the show
tomorrow okay
all right see you David all right and
stay safe down there wow wow wow
powerful powerful stuff from uh Luke
incredible incredible stuff and antifa
taking control
um of Luke's audio down there really
really remarkable stuff all right
incredible what a day what a day what a
day what a day uh all right thank you to
Donald Trump for the twitch Prime
subscription let me thank a few others
who signed up while we were talking to
Luke there uh Tino Torres Doyle keister
Jeff kulp
Chet Beach Zach Varga and Brendan
Snowden all signing up putting us at
103. folks if we get to 250 there will
be a second stream later today with uh
Trump's speech from Bedminster Let's uh
continue with super chats here
um Dave unfortunately I share your
opinion Trump won't see a day of jail
his uh rabid cult will not be deterred
all right
why was the national Guardsmen taken
down by a SWAT team and Trump is treated
with kid gloves and gets to go home
tonight
Fair
reminder that woman is a voter very
scary very scary and thanks to Dave
Harrington for the 50 Super Chat all
right folks let's listen to what's
happening with Fox news coverage the uh
arraignment is eight minutes away eight
minutes away and then Trump will be
arraigned August the 23rd they'll be the
Fox News debate uh and that'll be very
very important for us to get a read on
what the other candidates are going to
say uh about this case obviously it'll
be further down the road maybe you are
thinking about it will have changed a
little bit but I would look at that
debate whether or not Trump attends it's
going to be something that the other
candidates are going to have to talk
about I would look at that debate as a
time when people really start to sort of
put their flag out and and decide where
they're going to stand on this yeah
interestingly there are Republicans who
are starting to turn on Trump and we're
going to have coverage of some of them
to uh tomorrow on the podcast uh and I
think it uh you know a lot of these
people have been waiting for a get out
of jail free card how on Earth can I get
away from Trump and there are some
Republicans who are starting to say
listen this is now too much this has now
become a true distraction as if it
wasn't a distraction before thanks to
stealth dolphin for the twitch Prime
subscription I appreciate that also big
thank you to Jason sickmeyer who just
gifted a subscription on the website and
I really do uh appreciate that as well
we are moments away from Donald Trump's
arraignment in Miami Florida and it is
believed that there will be some kind of
press conference after the fact from
Trump's lawyers Trump not expected to
speak afterwards but Trump expected to
speak tonight from his home in
Bedminster the dude is asking how many
people do I think are there looks like a
low turnout could that mean his support
may be fading listen uh let's try to
find some of the like more far away
shots
tell me what you think in the audience
it doesn't seem to me that there's more
than a thousand people there
is that like I'm not good at estimating
crowd size but like are are there more
than a thousand people here
people generally agreeing with me
the most massive crowd ever yeah a lot
of people saying it's about a thousand
a billion people yeah I'm not sure
uh
the if you count the flags maybe thanks
to bakeable Brownie and Billy Carpenter
for the twitch Prime subscriptions I
very much appreciate that very very much
appreciate it
um all right let's take a listen ship
with him it's something he probably
wanted to keep but if we wanted to put
it in the library that's where you
negotiate with the archives and say can
we downgrade this so that it can be part
of the library
you have to get inside his head to know
that yes and we hope to I'll have an
interview on Monday uh June 19th at
Bedminster that'll be pretty in-depth
it's still on track we've triple
confirmed it so uh we'll be there Monday
the 19th but we look forward to the
answer to that question there you go
that'll be interesting for sure I want
to say thank you to Nicholas Carnes who
just sent a 500 Super Chat which I
believe is the most you can send
Nicholas thank you Nicholas says
appreciate you providing a medium space
and voice
thank you so much Nicholas I really do
appreciate that as we are standing by
here Trump's arraignment scheduled to
start in four minutes in four minutes
people are pounding pounding this
website is getting slapped to high
heaven I want to say thanks to Sean
Madden Mike Luby Andrew Turner Megan
scolaro James Ashcroft and Matthew
Holmes for signing up at joinpakman.com
the coupon code today is an indicted
again
if you are able only to subscribe to the
YouTube channel today
that is more than enough please do it if
you can get a membership at
joinpakman.com please do it and you can
use the coupon code indicted again look
at this thing this number is like a slot
machine it is shocking what is going on
I feel like I'm one of those people on a
mobility scooter in Vegas with the
cigarettes and the and the cheap drinks
and the the wheel is just going and
going and going it's really a crazy
crazy thing as we are continuing to
stand by for the arraignment just
moments away moments away let's
um let's listen to a couple of
voicemails about what we are seeing
right now hey David
I was just wondering if you think uh the
ghost of Pat Robertson is looking over
this stuff that's happening in Miami and
Miami
and just going I was wrong oh my God I
was so wrong you know it's hard to think
of what it is that Pat Robertson would
say about this that's for sure but uh
yeah you know
yeah I would have loved to avoided my
mug shot in 2016 for a felony charge
completely dismissed by the way but not
before my mugshot where I hadn't slept
in a week and had no eyebrows that mug
shot made it to the papers wow yeah that
is not good that when I was arrested for
holding a beer four months before I
turned 21 I had no mug shot thankfully
or but I can assure you uh that the
paparazzi would have now found that
picture and would have published it very
very strongly the latest news is that
indeed Trump is now in the courtroom
Trump has entered the courtroom and is
entering his plea he is under arrest he
is in the courtroom and the arraignment
is underway we are monitoring all
cameras outside the courtroom
extraordinarily closely we are expecting
words soon we may hear from Trump's
attorneys I can assure you when I was
arrested for holding a beer four months
shy of being 21 it was not a Bud Light
and it has nothing to do with politics
it has to do with it's an absolutely
terrible beer absolutely horrifying
horrifying horrifying beer uh super
chats continue to come in
thanks to the dude for gifting five
YouTube subscriptions uh Michael says
love your show kudos to Luke curious
about what security looks like there
Ollie says a thousand people of which
600 or media 200 are plain clothes
security a hundred are anti-trump
60-year Trump supporters and 40 are
confused tourists I think it's a little
more than that but uh but maybe maybe
even if Trump did nothing illegal
obviously not true says Brad how do
Republicans answer the ethical question
of why should Donald Trump have
sensitive nuclear secrets in his
bathroom because of the massive dumps
that he talked about on Election night
obviously obviously why why else big
thank you to Mark mangra Lily Anderson
Amanda Mayer Nicole barad and Carly
Sheehan all signing up on my website
pushing us to 123 also thanks to easy
peasy lemon squeezy for the twitch Prime
subscription you've got to love that
that is important let's see if we have
any other uh voicemails here related to
what is going on hi David I just wanted
to uh point out that the records act
presidential records act does say
establishes that the presidential
records automatically transfer into the
legal custody of the archivist as soon
as the president leaves office right
um is black and white uh thank you for
all that you do and uh hopefully I'll
talk to you in the future it is really
that clear I mean I hate to sometimes
you know one of the things that uh
obfuscaters will sometimes do is if
something is actually complicated they
will make it simple and if something is
simple they will make it complicated and
this is one of those cases where it is
quite simple I'm told that MSNBC has
Trump's lawyer on let's see if we can
pull that up here
uh
uh we are looking for a live feed of
MSNBC
let's see what we've got
two MSNBC special coverage of Donald
Trump's arraignment the former president
arrived the courthouse a little over an
hour ago via an underground garage he
has already been booked and digitally
fingerprinted he's expected to plead not
guilty to a 37 count indictment Mr Trump
is accused of Miss Hamlin classified
documents containing sensitive defense
secrets about everything from nuclear
programs to potential military
vulnerabilities but while he's not
expected to say much in court today
Trump has been saying plenty on social
media boy has he he's posted nearly all
right so I think we I think we more or
less understand what they are talking
about here and we will continue uh
awaiting Trump is reportedly in the
courtroom already for those who are
wondering so that's the the this
indictment uh this arraignment is well
well underway other super chats coming
in hi David hope you're doing well is
Trump officially facing jail time I just
joined so I don't know yeah Trump is
facing 536 years in prison what he would
plausibly end up with is a different
story
David were you addressed arrested for
drinking a keystone or a PBR you know
what's crazy is the day I was arrested
four months shy of 21 in an insane
situation for holding a beer I actually
hadn't even drank any of the beer I had
just gotten to a party and I was just
holding a beer I hadn't had a single sip
yet
and um you know how these police are
called at college parties and I just
happen to be standing by the door police
walk in and they go where's your ID they
come right to me because I was standing
in the exact wrong spot and
um celebrity attorney Mark garagos
represented me and he said it was the
Civil Rights issue of our time they
believed I was profiled for being a
left-handed Argentinian Hispanic Jew and
he was able to really push the court
back and uh it was all completely
expunged in fact when I got my Global
Entry card and was interviewed by um
some who does global entry I guess uh
DHS or whatever I had to uh I had to
address this issue and get a a legal
letter saying that no indeed it was all
taken care of it was all taken care of I
almost was not able to get my Global
Entry card because of that incident and
it was a sad day very sad day in
American history
they're coming after me they're
weaponizing the justice department and
it was all I mean it was totally woke
and we needed woke to die and they came
after me and they said listen uh you're
holding a beer and we're just not gonna
let teachers do it we're just not it's
not the they don't get the discretion
they don't get discretion
um okay we are standing by here moments
away I don't know how or why this froze
but we will get away from it
um any minute now this arraignment may
be over it is expected to be relatively
short although it could go long it could
go long
uh did Trump find a lawyer or is he
getting assigned a public defender I I
mean he had the two the two lawyers that
were representing him or with him in
court it's unclear whether he found like
a proper lawyer
would Trump serve time in a regular
prison or an extra crispy one oh that's
edgy
just watched Waco American apocalypse
can't help but see a similarity between
the cult and maggots absolutely I
recently read uh Jeff Gwynn's book about
Waco and it's hard not to see the
similarities David great work as always
today is my birthday and this is a great
present well happy birthday read over in
Europe hope all is going well hope all
is going well let's see what else we
have here
uh we're really just waiting for the end
of this and Trump expected to exit it
really might not be that much longer
because uh it is most of the stuff was
pre-negotiated in this Arrangement Riles
in Rhode Island just subscribed via
twitch Prime and puts us at 125. big
thank you to Terry schwarin senator
Larry Craig Sabrina Webb and Melinda
Sexton who just signed up on my website
using the code indicted again indicted
again let's listen to a couple other uh
voicemails here about what is going on
um
let's see here hey David uh I was
watching your stream today and you know
with tears you know streaming down my
eyelids or from my eyelids uh I have to
say I'm very sorry to hear about your
arrest uh when you were holding uh that
beer can at a college party yep and I'm
actually going to be riding to the White
House and you know request that you know
you get pardoned uh for that you know
I'm just a rest I agree again I'm sorry
to hear about your
um you know arrest uh back in your
college days I believe we need a letter
writing campaign to Joe Biden to try to
get me pardoned even though the record
was expunged and there was no
arraignment I still believe we could
find the records and that we could get
it expunged thanks to the bong Barian
for the twitch Prime subscription super
chats are dumping in Dave Harrington
gifting 10 YouTube memberships putting
us at 140 for the day uh thank you for
your good work says Philip
Australians are not happy about a
possible five eyes leak
greetings from Switzerland says Daniel
uh thank you very much I appreciate that
um
oh and big thank you to Maria liloff
Christensen Uriel caresti and Valerie
woodfack who just signed up on my
website ladies and gentlemen the
schedule for today is going to be as
follows this is what we're up against
Trump is in court right now he has
entered a plea of not guilty we now know
that Trump has entered his plea of not
guilty the proceedings are moving along
relatively quickly
Trump will exit we may hear from Trump's
lawyers they may only make a statement
or they may make a statement and answer
questions Trump will then fly We Believe
directly to the airport which airport
unclear whichever one is playing is at
he will then fly to Bedminster New
Jersey tonight at 8 15 PM Eastern Trump
is scheduled to speak from Bedminster
live my guess is he'll say things like
we won twice and we won by even more the
second time that's the type of thing I
expect Trump to say or he will say I met
with Abdul and showed him pictures of
his house or we will ban men from
women's sports those are the sorts of
things I expect from Trump
uh
and then between now and then I'm going
to work on tomorrow's show and do some
other things and hopefully I'll be back
and joining everybody tonight we have a
goal of 250 website members and twitch
subscribers to trigger that uh that
second stream tonight let's refresh our
MSNBC feed oh here we go let's listen
and he said he'll be doing this
permanently so he's going to represent
Donald Trump in this case and also Chris
uh Keys who is a Florida lawyer who has
been sort of off again on again with the
Trump team
um the Magistrate Judge welcomed
everyone to the southern district of
Florida Mr Trump sat Stone Face he's
wearing a blue suit and a red tie at the
table with his lawyers and with his
co-defendant Walt NADA
um and they waived a formal reading of
the indictment so it's a it was a really
pro forma Bare Bones Affair Andrea
and Andrew Weissman you've been nodding
when at least the description of who the
prosecutors were give us a quick
thumbnail on those three prosecutors
sure that's quite an experienced team uh
Julie uh the National Security person uh
has a lot of experience with these types
of cases uh and is particularly all
right so ladies and gentlemen the
indictment has been uh processed with an
arraignment We Believe Trump may be
leaving any moment now any moment now we
are monitoring multiple feeds here at
the Miami Federal Courthouse and Trump
pleading not guilty waiving a formal
reading of the indictment 37 felony
counts ladies and gentlemen lord of the
cup has just gifted a hundred
subscriptions putting us at 243 meaning
we are imminently close to triggering a
second live stream tonight from
Bedminster we should see if we can fly
Luke Beasley up to Bedminster in time
for that katil sagstad Katie Bryant and
Christina Harrison thanks for signing up
on my website I really do appreciate
that using the coupon code indicted
again we will have endless interviews
endless interviews tomorrow from Luke
Beasley who is down there in Florida I
think it's going to be an extraordinary
situation Joseph Altman says the voting
booth where Maga goes to die
can't wait until it's Kool-Aid drinking
time for the maggots no that's not I I
don't joke about murder suicide that's
that's a little I get the I get it but
we've got to be careful we got to be
careful I I'm not big on that
greetings from Ireland keep up the great
work thank you David
I uh I appreciate that
Trump's lawyer saying in court we most
certainly enter a not guilty plea Trump
pleading not guilty to all federal
charges we are standing by for Trump's
departure from the courthouse scheduled
for imminently imminently hi David I
have some breaking news for you um I
have someone on the ground there who
says that Trump has found legal counsel
it is a waffle waitress uh she will
claim an official statement that these
charges
um stem from him being smothering
covered uh with corrupt intent or at
least corrupt charges
um these charges are over easy and
should be 86 immediately
uh I was thinking they were sunny side
up to be perfectly Frank to be totally
and completely honest with you I don't
know that I agree with that call but uh
he's on the ground I'm not you know I
guess I have to defer we'll see
um if you're just joining us we are past
the stroke of 3 P.M in the East and
Donald Trump has been arraigned he has
pleaded not guilty to 37 charges and
waived a reading of the indictment he is
expected to leave relatively soon we are
expecting to hear from at least some of
Trump's lawyers
um any moment
any moment and that could happen
now it could be 20 minutes it could be
could be a little bit longer I want to
say thank you to Matthew Leslie who is
new member number 247 today I very much
appreciate that we are continuing to
follow various streams here let's listen
to the discussion you have
simultaneously a situation where
President Biden is also under
investigation by a special counsel for
mishandling classified information and
I'm just wondering if there's one
standard of Justice now that we've
gotten in an indictment and we've got an
itemized list of all these different
classified documents that they took from
a former president Trump where they
gave you the gist of what the document
was about they gave you the
classification level and they put in
there uh what the duration of his
illegal possession of them was is there
any good reason I can't think of one why
we shouldn't get a similar itemized list
to show that there's only one standard
of Justice a similar itemized list this
is really about Joe Biden this is really
about Joe Biden someone sent me an AI
mug shot of my arrest for holding the
beard you guys want to check it out
let's see if I can pull this thing up
here
here it is
this is when I was arrested
for holding a beer and they actually let
me keep the beer even during the mug
shot and it looks like this has me at
five nine and a half which I will gladly
take I absolutely accept five nine and a
half any day of the week
my nose is a little too big
in this rendering and I also have like a
weird Joker smile thing going on but
it's not bad
it's not bad I will accept it
um yeah
all right everybody stand by we may see
Donald Trump leaving the courthouse any
moment here as the arraignment may be uh
may have already come to a close I want
to say thanks to Johnny manogue and
Laurie
catazoni for gifting two subscriptions
folks We Are One new member away from
locking in another stream tonight from
Trump's Bedminster let's see how new oh
here's Trump's lawyer oh no this was
earlier
I'll play for you what she said our
democracy is founded upon
right now inside the courthouse has he
been arrested has he been fingerprinted
uh has a mug shot been taken walk us
through what's happening here now
president Trump is in a very unique
position where he doesn't need to be
given a mug shot obviously he's not a
Flight Risk he is the leading candidate
of the GOP at the moment
um he is going through a process that
has been coordinated with secret service
and it will all be handled seamlessly
thank you thank you guys
the attorneys all right so that's all
she said earlier as we are continuing to
cover the goings-on at the Miami
Courthouse and we may see Donald Trump
leave
any moment any moment quite frankly
let's listen to the fox live coverage
how if you're his attorney can you
operate
in good faith okay and it does appear as
though a statement will be made by
Trump's lawyers they are starting to set
up microphones so standby
attorneys right now and I think all
those new lead attorneys in South
Florida the District of South Florida
are Saints themselves wow I don't want
to get sandbagged too so to articulate
what I think you're saying is it says
attorney one which I believe is Corcoran
is the person that dealt with the search
and looked for everything and then 23
which is the person who signed affidavit
not attorney one is she had only limited
stuff that she was able to see and then
they move it now to moves it's the
bathroom in Mar-A-Lago they move it to
other rooms there's pictures things are
the bathroom is really the critical
place for this entire thing as we have
very quickly learned thank you to Corey
Sweet Baby Jones The Cutie for signing
up on my website and guaranteeing us a
second stream tonight from Trump's
Bedminster also thanks to Andre Garcia
number 251 and huge membership dumps
happening on Twitch 5 10 11 12 13 14 15
16.
putting us at 267 ladies and gentlemen I
can't thank everybody enough for the
support today we are waiting to hear
from Donald Trump's lawyers expected at
this a series of microphones momentarily
presumably to weigh in about what just
took place inside the courtroom Trump
pleading not guilty
strongly pleading Not Guilty By the way
it doesn't matter how strongly you plead
not guilty there's still going to be a
trial or at least it's going to be
adjudicated there may be a plea taken
it's still going to proceed as the point
that I am trying to make let's see what
else is on the minds of those who are
leaving uh voicemails here hey David I'm
watching your live stream can you
explain the crime fraud exception that
relates to Trump and his lawyer yeah
thank you put very simply and as always
I give you the caveat that I am not a
legal expert but I will explain this to
you as simply as I can the crime fraud
exception is an exception to
attorney-client privilege wherein if a
client is conspiring with and or
directing their lawyer to commit some
kind of crime uh including fraud or
trying to conspire with their lawyer
attorney privilege goes you could say
out the window or it gets flushed down
the toilet that is my understanding of
the crime fraud exception can anybody
can all any of the lawyers in the chat
confirm that
nobody can confirm that delightful
delightful no I see people confirming it
I appreciate that by the way out of
curiosity
if this is the first time you've ever
come across my content can you just let
me know in the chat it's really
interesting for us to see
whether people are here because they
already know me or if they were randomly
recommended this stream is this is this
the first time you've ever seen my
content can anybody say
nobody can say that's confusing
that's too bad
Hassan recommended me that doesn't seem
right I didn't think Hassan was
recommending any of my content anymore
that seems that seems like a lie ladies
and gentlemen
um okay any moment here we are going to
hear from Trump's lawyer tape of what's
going on it's the audacity of the thing
so on some notes you could say to
yourself why is the dojai coming after
Trump and then the other note you could
say why is Trump putting himself so
vulnerable that the doj could come after
him either way we look at it it's
overwhelming and I have to tell you
Andrew we may go to the trifecta or even
four for four we don't know what's going
on with the D.C federal investigation
into January 6 in Trump and we don't
know what's going on in Georgia over in
Atlanta with Fannie Willis when it comes
to those calls to find the votes over in
Georgia so this may not be the end we
may have even more that we're discussing
with Trump there may be a second Federal
indictment and there may be a state
indictment in Georgia in Georgia we are
standing by here for a press conference
believed to be Trump's lawyers but
challenging the search warrant
challenging the interview of his
attorney an attorney-client privilege
there are a lot of things that will be
challenged prior to getting to a trial
yeah absolutely Evan Corcoran his
attorney is one of the sources in this
indictment and they did they did require
and receive the right to talk to him but
we know that that's going to be one of
the things that the Trump folks are
going to argue that that was a breach of
attorney client privilege and it's a
sort of situation where everything
around the charges are the issues that
the Trump team is likely to press on
it's an election year we're in the
middle of uh you know the potential
prosecution of of the lead candidate
during that election year but it's
interesting Brett you know when we look
at some of the numbers and the support
right 81 percent of GOP voters say they
think this is a political prosecution
what a big surprise there
um 49 of of all voters say yeah there's
probably some political tinge to this
and I wonder you know even though it's
it's historic and unprecedented what
we're watching today even people who
follow this closely I think many of them
haven't read this this document of
course they haven't which is why the
special counsel Jack Smith came out in
that short announcement during your show
last week and said in that talking to
the Press read the indictment yeah read
the indictment I recommend you to move
forward with a speedy process and it
lays it all out not many people
obviously read the indictment but what's
in there for the legal experts who you
know side with the special counsel is is
very troubling and you have some
politicians talking about that on the
flip side you had Senator Marco Rubio
earlier today laying out a very
articulate case of why the justice
department and the special counsel
should not have made this jump and how
badly very very country at this moment
in time and we're going to be playing
out those Arguments for days and weeks
to come
indeed we will uh Brett thanks for being
with us standby if you would one of
former president Trump's rivals in the
2024 race today on the steps of that
Courthouse do we want to hear from Vivek
ramaswamy or do we want to go to
something different let me know I I'm we
can listen or we can not I don't know if
people care what vivec has to say
some people saying yes
some people saying no
all right let's see
uh-oh okay we'll get to that in just a
moment Republican presidential candidate
Vivek Raman Swami joins me now uh Vivek
good to have you with us today thank you
so much good to see you um you're you're
moving around quickly today you were
down in Miami at the courthouse and we
have you here this afternoon so thank
you very much for
all right let's listen to you earlier
today watch this
God what did Biden tell Jack Smith what
did Biden tell Merrick Garland right
what did Merrick Garland tell special
prosecutor Jack Smith
so that's an important question
um the president has said you know we
have nothing to do with this they're
doing your thing what exactly are you
looking for hoping for and do you think
you're going to get it I certainly
expect to the law requires these
government agencies including the doj to
comply with the Freedom of Information
Act request and I want to be really
clear it would be easier for me if
president Trump were eliminated from
competition in this race but I wanted to
stand on the side of principle to do
what so many he's super principled super
principled to do which is to actually be
skeptical get to the bottom of what's
behind what I see as a politicized
indictment and the thing that made me
actually take that step is that I did
read that indictment actually and you
know I bring my legally trained eyes to
this as well right there were a lot of
selective omissions of both fact and law
from that indictment not one mention of
the presidential records act not one
mentioned of the 2012 case the leading
federal case that interpreted the
presidential records act in the context
of the Clinton stock man this guy is
really unbearable truly truly unbearable
let's see what msnbc's got tell me where
the landmines are so I don't
accidentally step on them and so I can't
speak to that specific part of this case
you know I came into you know the
Mar-A-Lago side of this thing a little
bit later I was initially just on the
January 6 case so I can't speak to that
portion of it I do think you know that
this is the type of thing that really
from both sides had there been more
Communications more honest
Communications from the beginning things
could have probably been avoided and I'm
not going to just lay the blame on just
one side or the other but certainly you
know from what I saw the doj team wasn't
really negotiating or communicating the
way that normal USA assistant U.S
attorneys would either
Tim you've been great this entire case
is avoidable all right yeah yeah
um
for you to say that you think it's
avoidable and and we appreciate your
time it's a personal tragedy thank you
so much Tim we do appreciate you
spending so much time let me go to Neil
katyal because we don't know we're
hoping one of our other folks will come
out of the courtroom and give us some
idea of what happens next and what the
magistrate had to say but what are all
right so we're standing by for that
press conference very importantly
um let's get to a few other super chats
that are coming in shakaseki saying when
can we have a Luke Beasley liberal clock
co-stream that could be a while it could
be a while to line that up Mary says I
Found You The Night of the fetterman Oz
debate well welcome back Marion thank
you so much for the Super Chat
thank you for your professionalism
integrity and your commitment since day
one thank you thank you
this is Corey Sweet Baby Jones The Cutie
new website subscriber I'm A hip-hop
artist first time Watcher referred by
Mark and snow track love the show peace
all right well thank you very much
will the judge be able to limit Donald
Trump's comments regarding the case
after today's indictment the the judge
could the expectation was that the judge
would not but the judge absolutely could
uh without a doubt
um hey everyone be sure to support
Progressive media as we approach 2024
thanks what you do Deepak appreciate it
sir I'm starting to think the indictment
document is fake since no one came up to
Trump With Tears in their eyes I'm
starting to think the same thing
I'm starting to wonder myself it's a
very important point I want to say thank
you so many people are signing up on my
website that the website is almost
crashing Barbara Cody Antonio Monroy
Kemble Carpenter John Gentry
senator Larry Craig and Gordon Hall it's
me and Mike Burkhart Stephen Martinez
and Arlene Causley Gene Phillips and Ben
Cole putting us at
286. whoa what just happened an
incredible and stunning number I also
want to get a couple more voicemails in
here let's take a listen
hey there's a hilarious shot of the
crowd down in Miami the paid stand-ins
from for Trump supporters and I'm sure
they're paid they all have to be paid by
his campaign to come out to show but
anyway there's a there's a funny shot
two
on a corner shot
there's a lot of shirts out there that
um
black uh black for Trump
and trumpsters aren't racist yeah and
the funny thing is is the black man has
the trumpsters aren't racist and a white
man has black surprise on so you know
they're just handing out the shirts and
they just came out the wrong shirt to
the wrong the wrong uh
race uh you know a black man
what trumps aren't racist trumpsters
aren't racist and a white man who is
Black for 12th time I didn't see them
they just showed it again they just
showed it again
all right well so a lot very much seems
to be happening a lot a lot is happening
down there it's impossible to follow all
of these different stories and uh
narratives one bit of breaking news the
judge said Trump cannot speak to his
co-defendant waltin nauta the reason
this is so relevant
is that this guy wall team is what's
called Trump's body man he's with Trump
everywhere you see him in the background
of every single shot when Trump's on the
golf course while teen is next to Trump
also wearing golf attire when waltene is
um uh with Trump in other scenarios he's
wearing a suit he's always with Trump
and now Trump is not allowed to speak to
him which is really an interesting
situation that we will have to see how
it plays out and if Trump is there any
way to enforce that does Trump pay
attention to that who on Earth knows but
that is interesting prosecutors have
also stipulated that they don't consider
Donald Trump a Flight Risk
but that Trump cannot speak to any of
the witnesses either these are all bits
of news that are coming out as we stand
by for the exiting of trump
from the courthouse from the courthouse
this feed has ended
uh and we're we're standing by let's
listen partially right when he comes
someone a senator like Vance are saying
results say everything results of your
jury of your peers the sixth amendment a
fair trial that's what matters to me
okay we do Andrew have this new shot if
you're just joining us here uh or
approaching the bottom of the hour it
does look like uh and we can kind of
tell we haven't confirmed this the
arraignment is over yes uh so possibly
uh the Trump motorcade will be leaving
the courthouse very soon there uh that's
kind of the entrance exit there down
into the underground parking garage
where the motorcade went in initially so
we're going to keep this shot up uh
we're gonna try to get some of our
reporters there down on the ground in
Florida just for a scene Setter of all
the commotion all the supporters and
opponents of the former president right
who decided to come out today uh to you
know voice their theme soon as their
support and this uh really momentous
news story here so uh Andrew uh stay
with us here we're going to take just a
quick commercial break we still want to
talk to you about all these all right so
we there is every reason to believe that
we are going to hear from Trump's
lawyers momentarily
um and I think that that is going to be
an interesting moment we will my
prediction is they will be defiant but
maybe not exactly principled that would
be that would be my guess that's the way
these people uh often are
um okay I've gotten a request
to make another one of these
contributions to a small twitch streamer
just to dump into their stream and give
them 10 or 20 bucks and I'm glad to do
that it's an interesting thing but last
time we had a little bit of trouble
finding uh exactly who we were gonna do
that with
um someone is saying that I should do it
with someone named Crazy Cat I guess I'm
gonna try that let's try it let's just
give another one of these uh I don't
even know what this is oh I'm not logged
in here hold on a second
let's do it this way
uh okay
let's just gift some bits here let me
move my monitor Okay let's listen
unmute five and snack
I have no idea what's going on we're
just going to give this person 20 bucks
okay
we've barely made it or I guess it's
gonna be 10.
oh no two okay here we go
great stuff oh my God what is happening
all right we got to get off of this oh
my God I just this is not appropriate
content for this stream really we just
gifted 20 oh my God what is who's
someone set me up
oh my God okay they're sitting back down
this is CR we just gifted this person
twenty dollars
okay
okay that backfired horribly never do
that again and in the future I'm gonna
pick everyone that we are donating to
that was wholly inappropriate given what
we have going on here uh somebody
screwed me and I really don't appreciate
that okay we just gave someone twenty
dollars no idea who that was no idea
what they're doing but that was really a
crazy crazy moment let's get back to
um let's let's get back to this that was
really I'm gonna have to pick going
forward so under the statute the court
will appoint what's called a court
security officer they'll come up with
procedures that'll how to deal with
those documents they'll have to be
reviewed in a skiff uh the defense
lawyers are going to have to get
clearance to do that so those aren't
delaying tactics I mean that is going to
take some time and we're going to see
what kind of a schedule judge Cannon
says
what do I think the trial date is and
people have said three weeks the four I
mean the answer I don't mean to be glib
about it is whatever judge Camden says
that's when the trial date's gonna be it
doesn't that doesn't that really raise
the whole issue of Judge Cannon and
obviously the proof will be in how she
takes how she proceeds here but isn't
that the main drawback for the
prosecution in being in Miami where the
judge
does not have great experience most
judges there all right we are standing
by this on the left seems to be the ramp
from which Donald Trump's motorcade is
going to leave I still am under the
impression that we're expecting a
statement or a press conference from
Donald Trump's lawyers once Trump leaves
and goes directly back to the airport so
that is going to be um any any moment I
believe any moment I believe
uh all right other uh oh super chats are
coming in
jinsu victim says I was a Christian
conservative from 02 to 15 Trump is why
I'm an atheist Democrat now thank you
Pac-Man Brian Tyler Cohen Maddow Titus
and Jesse dollimore all right thank you
very much very much appreciate that
in a very very powerful super chat still
coming in here which you absolutely love
to see other voicemails
um
I have one other actually I don't have
any other new voicemails from the Stream
that are here okay no big deal
um
very very good
all right every oh it's dirt let's see
what dershowitz is up to Iran uh he
wishes he wouldn't have said that
um so I wrote an article yesterday
saying what if both the justice
department and Trump are guilty uh
they've both done wrong things there you
go does what Trump did rise to the
standard of what I call the Richard
Nixon test
I don't think so he didn't destroy
evidence he didn't um
bribe Witnesses he didn't do any of
those things
um and I agree with one of your previous
guests there's an argument other people
have committed worse crimes
uh there isn't provision of it that
deals with Espionage and people are in
prison for that but this merely deals
with possession of classified material
if they had decided to prosecute Hillary
Clinton or
um Joe Biden or pants they would have
prosecuted them too under the Espionage
Act it doesn't require Espionage it's a
statute whose name ought to be changed
to improper possession of classified
material this guy but the Espionage Act
makes it sound like you know Trump had
or sold material to to to Putin right
that that's yeah that's what gets a lot
of people Alan is it sounds so serious
and what you're just suggesting that's
not people who know nothing thinks that
think this means Trump was a spy whether
he should have them uh
go ahead the biggest
issue is going to be the relationship
between the presidential record Act and
the Espionage Act presidential record
actors you know enacted a half century
after the Espionage right and there has
to be a relationship when you read the
text of both of the statutes you almost
feel like all of these people making
these defenses
are just pathetic in a sense there's
like a pathetic nature to these defenses
that they're coming up with of trump
um David jonason from Iceland says belly
girl is leading Trump's legal team go
back to her exactly exactly
uh
Dylan beaumel has just signed up on my
website with the coupon code indicted
again that is today's coupon code Donald
Trump has been arraigned Donald Trump
has entered a not guilty plea Donald
Trump has been ordered not to speak to
any of the witnesses no no nor his uh
alleged co-conspirator and we are
awaiting Donald Trump leaving the
courthouse uh on the way to the airport
he will fly back to his Bedminster home
in New Jersey and we will expect to hear
from him there tonight there will be a
second live stream tonight important
second live stream tonight
um where we will
um hear probably the same old grievances
from Trump quite frankly I don't expect
anything particularly new Super Chat
says if Trump dies Trump Army will dive
into conspiracy theories of course
but what do you think they will do five
years from now who will they follow who
knows that there are a lot of ifs ands
and buts awaiting us there and I don't
have it it is mere speculation mere
speculation
um and it I just don't think it makes
sense to guess at this point in time
Kathleen sends a 10 super chat no
question or comment thanks Kathleen
appreciate that blah blah Martha under
the rules of law be the person who's
being investigated has the right to look
at her emails or his emails and decide
which ones are relevant for the
government to scrutinize and now all of
a sudden Trump brings this up because
again it's smoke and mirrors and say oh
it's unfair the only what's unfair here
I don't know because that case that's
been laid out by Jack Smith it seems to
me it's so strong that you don't hear
even Trump's supporters trying to make
the case that it's weird
after Hillary we've only heard one side
of this case right and yes there are
absolutely I've read this several times
this indictment and there are things in
here that are disturbing as we have said
over and over on this show with many
guests okay there are also things in
these other cases that are disturbing
and you seem to be able to just say oh
everybody did what they were supposed to
do there but the problem is that half
the country sees investigations as
either politically sunk or politically
elevated depending on the wins that
happen to be backing them so you may
have confidence that those cases were
investigated clearly
a lot of Americans don't have that
confidence they see my goodness so how
could it take five years
to investigate Hunter Biden's taxes and
what's on a laptop can you explain that
to me what is taking five years Juan if
it isn't back burnered
if it isn't back burner maybe they're
having trouble finding evidence that
would say to them that a drug addicted
you know sex-addled kid uh the president
President Biden's son uh no we can make
a case and feel confident in making this
case that it wouldn't be viewed as
political and that a jury would convict
this really these Fox hosts are so
brazenly and openly running very
pathetic interference here it's it's
almost sad to see
Grando Reaper says my father-in-law told
me the entire indictment is by Trump's
design some kind of 4D chess he wants to
be a martyr to save us from the liberal
Elite these people are beyond help very
true
Rhett Proctor says you helped me become
a progressive liberal after my cousin
told me to watch your channel in tyt I
will always vote blue
D Dash says what's particularly
frightening about all of this is the
backlash that will ensue from his Die
Hard supporters
soda popper says watching this on my
lunch break thanks for the laughs and
the engaging commentary David sir well
thank you
Adrian says just a statement but Trump
could die at 150 years old however the
cult would still say it's a conspiracy
and the government killed him
David sir I say this as a strong man
with tears in my eyes streaming down my
face love the good work you do sir well
thank you Samuel
Nicholas says do you personally know any
of the other Progressive YouTube people
Brian Tyler Cohen Young Turks Etc yeah
absolutely Brian and I speak on the
phone sort of regularly actually
um it's funny I've mentioned this before
I basically don't speak on the phone
and like the and my phone never even
Rings like I use my phone to text no one
calls me I never call anyone
almost the only person who calls me and
just randomly is Brian it'll it will
have no call scheduled I'll pick it up
and it's just Brian he's like hey dude
did you see this did you see that I saw
your video about this thing the other
thing uh and I know Jank and Anna of
course and Kyle Kolinski Sam Cedar and
Farren cousins
um
I don't really know any of the
Revolutionary leftists
if you know what I'm talking about we
don't really we don't really talk
uh let's see what else we have here Nick
says say what do you think the chances
are that a UFO lands in the middle of
this I find it highly unlikely that a
UFO will land in the middle of these
proceedings I really do thanks to Ryan
Soros
as well or Sorrows Ryan sorrows and
Michelle Moore who just signed up on my
website using the code indicted again I
invite you to sign up on my website with
that coupon code I also want to remind
you we will be coming to you with
another live stream tonight Trump will
be making a speech at Bedminster
um make sure you've subscribed on
YouTube for free or followed on Twitch
for free and then you'll be notified
tonight
about that stream uh really easy thing
to do Roz says when he dies they will
claim he resurrects maybe
maybe wouldn't wouldn't be the last uh
thing I'd imagine
wouldn't be a huge huge shocker right
now they've brought on
um Republican senator
what was This Woman's name I forget her
name let's see what she has to say
redact the fact that there are seven
recordings that are held by this
executive now what we don't know Martha
is their full reasoning for this and we
got into this during my questioning of
the Deputy FBI director today in
committee he admitted that yes they did
the redactions so we'll drill down on
this a little bit further did they do it
to Shield the buyers did they do it to
protect the source oh my God it is one
of the most impactful days in American
history and she's talking about the
bidens again it it's it's almost Beyond
parity it really is
it it's just shocking shocking stuff
let's get a look at some of the other
videos from on the ground in Miami that
are coming in
uh
uh let's see what we have here
let's take a listen we just have
breaking news Trump did confirm
Ed not guilty to all charges just now
okay fantastic so he's pled not guilty
there's no travel restrictions there's
no cash Bond imposed so he's free to
continue campaigning living his life as
normal the way that we would as this
process plays out and uh man it's gonna
be it's gonna be one heck of a campaign
season buckle up everybody we're in for
a ride wow they're all super super
excited about what's going on I guess a
CNN reports that Trump was twiddling his
thumbs the former president uh took a
seat uh at the defendants table he was
wearing his trademark red tie with a
dark suit uh he had a very serious look
on his face uh periodically had his arms
folded once in a while would uh would
speak to one of his attorneys Todd
Blanche and Todd Blanche is one of the
law is the lawyer who stood before the
judge when he was asked to enter The
Plea he uh said we most certainly enter
a plea not guilty your honor and that
was a essentially near the beginning of
the of the hearing these hearings are
typically very perfunctory they're very
short and we got to the point very very
quickly the former president uh entered
the room probably about 30 40 minutes
before the judge uh we you know we
couldn't see exactly when he entered the
room because the televisions in the in
the room we were in were not turned on
immediately uh but you know the uh we
saw uh you know the lawyers take their
seats on the former president uh sort of
twiddling his thumbs while he waited for
the proceedings to take his place he
never looked around the room uh very
sort of glum look on his face a glum
Trump twiddling his thumbs is really
just a delight to hear about uh okay
there is starting to be some activity
here in front of the courthouse I
believe oh yeah soon Trump will leave
court so Trump hasn't left yet he's
going to leave very very soon so we're
going to stand by for that in the
meantime uh I do have other things that
uh that that I want to get to let's see
what other Clips we have from on the
ground in Miami and remember Luke
Beasley is on the ground for us and
we're going to have all sorts of uh all
sorts of videos and interviews tomorrow
conservative media with beers in their
hands let's see
the Sun and they're preaching communism
but look where they live look where they
Blackline mother people live they have
become rich do you think they care about
Hispanics do you think they care about
Black Americans no they don't they
denigrade us they want us to die
crossing the border
department when Daniel Ortega
opponents was the first one this is
crazy stuff
he goes around the world preaching about
them all right here we go Donald Trump
is now leaving the courthouse uh leaving
the courthouse leaving the courthouse
okay
um let's see what is going to give us a
sense of what's going on it's okay now
there's a commotion it seems people are
coming out in this main screen on the
right and Trump expected over here on
the left it's becoming a little bit
chaotic which may not come as a complete
and total shock to you
let's see what gives us the best sense
of what is taking place we will keep it
here
um a lot of wild stuff just it the crazy
just is everywhere it really is a thanks
to Raymond Merrick as well as Renee
otolakowski
Sandra Wagner Samuel Bennett and Ryan
Hovey
all of whom signed up on my website this
puts us at 299 ladies and gentlemen
um it seems as though Trump's motorcade
is about to depart it seems we will
imminently be hearing from Trump's
lawyers assuming they are indeed going
to speak which is never it's never a
guarantee super chats continue coming in
Sid says sir I come to you with tears in
my eyes do you believe AI will trick
Maga Republicans regarding Hunter Biden
evidence they fall for Onion articles
and satire often yeah it's completely
feasible that that will happen
uh
all right very good Trump imminently
leaving and then the next stream my
thought guy so here's my thought about
the timing for tonight's stream
Trump is scheduled to speak at 8 15
Eastern so normally I would start at 7
45. however Trump is almost always
really late
so maybe I should plan to start at like
eight because it's probable Trump won't
actually speak until sometime between
what 8 30 and 9 or something like that
he's always like 45 minutes late exactly
exactly uh all right let people are
saying CBS News has better shots
let's go to that
CV CBS News have any contact with a bout
okay here we go
uh maybe we'll trade in uh we don't need
to trade let's just go here
okay
so we are standing by also by the way it
seems like right side broadcasting is
getting ready to do some kind of thing
some kind of thing which who knows uh
all right so the motorcade is ready and
we are expecting Trump at any moment
here at any moment very powerful stuff
Jason Kuntz thank you for the website
membership you are number 300 today 300
let's go for 350 as the kids these days
say
um other super chats coming in no hold
on did I avoid okay let's get to a
couple voicemails here
uh
uh where are my voicemails hey David
this is Mike from Sacramento
um with Donald Trump's impending court
date uh being on Tuesday I like to
unfortunately make a prediction I think
that his his supporters will do
something crazy
tomorrow I don't know if it'll like
prevent him from going to to the
courthouse or you know uh or whatever
but it'll it'll definitely turn ugly
whatever well so far that hasn't
happened fortunately I don't want it to
be ugly I don't want violence I don't
want crimes committed or any of it any
of it so I I do hope that that doesn't
ultimately happen thanks to Barrett
Urban who just signed up at
joinpakman.com and his new member number
301 today very much appreciate that and
we are going to be
um
I I don't want there you know I got a
bunch of emails from people saying David
you leftists want there to be violence
no I don't what when have I ever
implicitly or explicitly called for
violence never ever ever ever ever
it has just never happened I've never
done it I've never done it all right
thanks to easy Hendrix for the twitch
Prime subscription let's listen to a bit
of the CBS news coverage he didn't
actually say what his plea was his
attorney Todd Blanche entered it on the
former president's behalf it doesn't
need to speak at all he didn't speak at
all uh and sat there as I say rather
rather Sullen uh with a frown on his
face arms folded hunched over a bit uh
he looked directly at the judge
throughout and it was only that one
moment at the end when the judge
suggested that his his work here is done
because the case will be handed off to
District Court Judge Eileen Cannon uh
Trump smiled when he when it was uh
clear that the magistrate judges all
right the motorcade getting ready to
depart
gwj says David if you do another random
stream donations I suggest someone
playing Legend of Zelda alright I'm
willing to look into that for sure set
of hearings happened in Miami where they
certainly have the size in the
courthouse and the security footprint to
handle everything that is here today
there are
dozens if not hundreds of trump
supporters on the Plaza there are dozens
if not hundreds of members of the media
I want to bring in Graham Cates and
we're going to do a little uh
maneuvering to get him in here Graham
Cates was actually in the courtroom
itself for this roughly 45-minute
proceeding this arraignment of former
president Trump in this initial
appearance if you're just joining us I
see people wondering what's going on yes
the um the arraignment is over and
apparently the judge was in tears no
that's not true uh at any moment now
Trump is going to be departing the
courthouse the judge was calling him Mr
Trump there was these kind of little
differences and then he was ordered to
uh sign uh personal surety bond that
said he you know wouldn't commit another
crime and that um he's being told not to
communicate with any potential witnesses
that will be listed by the prosecution
without the case itself about the facts
of the case one thing that was mentioned
earlier I want to reaffirm because I had
left the courtroom by this point he can
travel domestically in our
internationally as he runs for the White
House yeah and the judge asked the
special counsel about that do you have
any issues with him traveling and they
said no we don't want to impose any
restrictions on him for that and they
actually didn't really ask for any
restrictions it was the judge's idea to
impose this one extra restriction which
is that even though so many of the
potential Witnesses are employees a
former president Trump or involved in
his everyday life that he may not
discuss within any of the facts of the
case and they're going to get this
limited list of people uh who from from
here on out you can see you can talk to
but just not about the case all right
Nora the 45-minute proceeding that's
wrapped up but not completed while
trinada has to come back for arraignment
or have his arraignment soon
McFarland and Graham Cates with all that
inside information and color from inside
the courthouse want to bring in our
senior White House and political all
right any moment the motorcade will be
departing voicemails or dumping in for
many of you fine folks hi this is Kyle
I'm here in the heart of red State
Tennessee it's great to see Trump
getting indicted it's a great day for
democracy to show that no one's Above
the Law and I'm just so happy to see it
finally happening and there's more to
come so stay tuned all right here is
Donald Trump in this so that what you're
seeing from the left of the screen
behind the tree
the motorcade is waiting for the another
part of the motorcade to come out from
let's see if I can actually show you ah
here it is this is it okay so this is a
better angle part of the motorcade was
outside this underground garage Trump
was in the underground garage so
essentially his SUV will join this
portion of the motorcade and they are
coming out now as you can see uh Trump
will presumably go directly to the
airport that's what we believe people
fly up to Bedminster and uh something
delaying the departure here
um to some degree to some degree let's
listen to voicemails
David incredible stuff just want to let
you know we were watching from
California
the family went to uh Puesto La Jolla
and it was incredible
uh we really like the filet and carnitas
tacos the most but the sauces were
certainly good uh particularly the green
tomatillo thank you yeah I recommended a
particular Taco spot in La Jolla and I
guess somebody took the advice and then
they went but we do have a lot of other
stuff going on today so I do think it's
important hi David my name is Mark I'm
from Wisconsin it was so enjoyable
watching you give this away to random
tiny streamers on Twitch the other day
that I was inspired with tears in my
eyes to go and give my Prime sub instead
of to you I'm sorry to say to the
smallest Legos Builder I could find it
was someone building a custom Saint
Bernard and I hope they were happy to
get mice up there you go all right well
that's totally fine that's absolutely
and completely fine
Dave can you cover Newsome on Fox news
last night it's on today's podcast folks
the podcast went live about an hour and
a half ago I Gavin knew some destroyed
Sean Hannity last night and I covered
the entire thing on today's podcast As
Trump leaves the courthouse let's listen
to the sights and sounds uh our
correspondent Leonardo Feldman actually
we're not we're not hearing any of it
there uh okay here we've got the chopper
made any eye contact with the special
counsel Jack Smith the person who is
bringing these charges on behalf of the
justice department we were curious
whether or not we'd see any sort of uh
you know Stand Down Behavior between the
two men and it appears that they did not
interact at all Trump however against
choosing to stay very quiet and allowing
his lawyers to speak on his behalf it's
also understanding that uh Walt NADA the
aid that was also charged in relation to
this case did not have a formal
arraignment he is still seeking legal
counsel at this point someone to
represent him down here in Florida but
that the same rules are likely to apply
for him as the judge ordering today that
Trump not discussed this case with those
Witnesses uh people that may be
influenced by uh the events that
happened at Mar-A-Lago throughout 2022
our producer though of course still
selling we're gonna get some more
information and Martha of course we'll
send it out once we have it okay mark
thank you Mark Meredith on the scene at
the courthouse in Miami the live aerial
shop that you're watching right now is
former president Donald Trump the 45th
president of the United he has left he
has left he has left
uh
uh and it is absolute and total chaos
everywhere let's see what's happening
here
[Music]
[Applause]
oh now it's actually getting crazy
[Music]
what is happening here
[Applause]
what on Earth
this isn't really an escaped convict is
it there's no way that that's what that
is that couldn't possibly be right he's
just dressed as a prisoner
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
hard to know what's going on
[Applause]
okay here's a guess an anti-trump
protester
South America America first
we love America
wow things are really starting to get a
little bit nuts huh getting a little bit
crazy and so we'll hopefully learn from
some of our reporters down on the ground
of why he was taken into custody there
uh but so uh some excitement a little
bit there
outside of the courthouse along the
route of the motorcade there and now the
motorcade continues to go we're gonna
just listen in to see if we have sound
on some of this
no it's just Chopper audio we apologize
that's not a fun sound to listen to so
I'll keep talking here as we continue to
follow this is really getting a little
bit Bonkers this is like look at this
look at this scene
thank you
all right everybody I think that this is
probably a good time to end this stream
we uh I actually have to now go into
working on tomorrow's show and then I'll
be back with everybody tonight for the
second stream the second stream will be
tonight probably around 7 45 or uh or 8
P.M all right so I appreciate everybody
who joined remember the best way to do
life today is to make sure you're
subscribed to the YouTube channel make
sure you're following us on Twitch it's
all look at look at this
um and then you'll be notified tonight
when we go live again thank you to
everybody who signed up supported sent
comments of every kind
this is only the first of two streams
today it is the first of two streams
today and I hope to see you back tonight
Trump has been indicted he has been
arraigned he will now be flying to
Bedminster and we will pick it up with
all of the comments made between now and
then and and and
Trump's speech tonight stream two of two
eight pm Eastern 5 p.m Pacific it will
be a televised temper tantrum from
Donald Trump we will see you there